OK, everybody. Ready? Ready? Lights, camera, Christmas.
好的，各位。准备好了吗？准备好了？灯光，摄像，圣诞节。
Well, my parents say that I can't have a dog.
嗯，我父母说我不能养狗。
This is Pirecua, age 11.
这是皮雷库亚，11岁。
So I wanted like another animal that is fuzzy and it walks around.
所以我想要另一种毛茸茸的、能到处走动的动物。
I'm not really a pet sort of person. I think she knew she couldn't get a dog, basically.
我不是那种喜欢养宠物的人。我想她基本上知道自己不能养狗。
This is Linda, her mom. Linda is a reporter at WBEZ, the public radio station that's our home.
这是琳达，她的妈妈。琳达是WBEZ的记者，WBEZ就是我们的公共广播电台总部。
So a guinea pig was, I think, something she felt she could actually ask for. You know, this is second place, I guess. It's still fuzzy and walks around.
所以我觉得，豚鼠是她觉得自己真正可以要求的东西。你知道，我想这算是第二选择吧。它仍然毛茸茸的，还能到处走动。
Linda's husband is Mexican. And the kids lived in Mexico when they were smaller, so they don't write to Santa to ask for what they want. The Mexican tradition at Christmas is to write to the Three Kings.
琳达的丈夫是墨西哥人。孩子们小的时候住在墨西哥，所以他们不会写信给圣诞老人要礼物。墨西哥的圣诞节传统是写信给三位国王。
So she wrote this letter to the three kings. And do you want me to read it?
所以她给三位国王写了这封信。你想让我读一下吗？
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, could you read it?
好啊，好啊。你能读一下吗？
All right. It says,
好的。信上说，
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
She says, like, dear Three Kings, I hope you're doing very well. I hope you're well.
她说，亲爱的三位国王，希望你们一切都好。希望你们身体健康。
I thought that was a nice touch.
我觉得这是一个很好的细节。
That is a nice touch.
确实是一个很好的细节。
Yeah.
是啊。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
She says, this year, I was thinking of asking for a guinea pig. And then she writes-- she has, like, an arrow. She's like, it's like an afterthought. She wrote, a real one, [SPEAKING SPANISH] Then she goes on and asks for some other things. But what she really wanted, and she has this whole list of things. But honestly, I don't ever remember her talking about anything else except the guinea pig.
她说，今年，我本来想问问能不能要一只豚鼠。然后她写道——她加了一个箭头。就像是事后才想到的。她写道，一只真的，[说西班牙语] 然后她继续要求其他一些东西。但她真正想要的，她有一整张清单。但老实说，我不记得她除了豚鼠以外还谈论过其他任何东西。
So comes the big morning. This was two years ago. Pirecua was just nine. The Three Kings did, in fact, bring her a guinea pig. And, of course, she was thrilled. She named it Luna.
于是那个重要的早晨到了。那是两年前。皮雷库亚才九岁。三位国王确实给她带来了一只豚鼠。当然，她激动不已。她给它取名叫露娜。
The guinea pig was like in her arms, and it was running around her bed. And she was just in love. Well, that lasted about an hour before I just noticed she was scratching her forearms a lot.
豚鼠在她的怀里，还在她的床上跑来跑去。她完全被迷住了。好吧，这只持续了一个小时，我就注意到她在不停地抓挠前臂。
And she said that they were hives. I was allergic to my guinea pig.
她说那是荨麻疹。我对我的豚鼠过敏了。
She was completely scared that I would give the guinea pig away immediately. And I think her one goal was to keep the guinea pig. So she definitely did not complain about the hives.
她非常害怕我会立刻把豚鼠送走。我想她当时唯一的目标就是留下这只豚鼠。所以她绝对没有抱怨荨麻疹的事。
They were big, red blotches the size of silver dollars. Pirecua, however, would not be deterred.
那是大块的红斑，有银元那么大。然而，皮雷库亚并没有退缩。
She still held it. She tried for a while. I was like, maybe if you cover yourself up. So what she started doing was she would put on this full face mask that she usually used on the coldest days in Chicago.
她还是抱着它。她坚持了一段时间。我说，也许你可以把自己包起来。所以她开始做的是，戴上她在芝加哥最冷的日子里通常戴的那种全脸面具。
It was black. All you could see were her eyes. Linda showed me a photo of the full getup. You can see it on our website.
它是黑色的。你只能看到她的眼睛。琳达给我看了那套装备的照片。你可以在我们的网站上看到它。
She basically looks like a Zapatista rebel.
她基本上看起来像个萨帕塔武装分子。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
She's got a long-sleeve shirt. She's got her winter gloves on. And in the winter gloves is the little guinea pig peeking out from her hands.
她穿着长袖衬衫。她戴着冬天的手套。在冬天的手套里，那只小豚鼠从她的手里探出头来。
Meanwhile, paper towels stick out several inches from the gloves.
同时，纸巾从手套里伸出来好几英寸。
So that there's absolutely no gap between her long-sleeve shirt and the gloves.
这样她的长袖衬衫和手套之间就没有任何缝隙了。
She looks like a young terrorist.
她看起来像个年轻的恐怖分子。
[LAUGHS] With a cute guinea pig.
[笑] 带着一只可爱的豚鼠。
[CHUCKLES] With a cute guinea pig. Exactly. It looks like she's taken the guinea pig hostage or something.
[轻笑] 带着一只可爱的豚鼠。没错。看起来她把豚鼠劫持为人质了什么的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Pirecua is devoted to Luna still-- lets it run around her room, makes sure it's fed. In third grade, she had a photo of Luna that she pasted onto a little hand-drawn cardboard frame with a little cardboard leg that she would prop up on her desk at the beginning of every school day facing her.
皮雷库亚对露娜依然忠诚——让它在房间里跑来跑去，确保它吃饱。三年级时，她把露娜的照片贴在一个手工制作的硬纸板相框上，上面有一个小硬纸板支架，每天上学前她都会把它立在书桌上，正对着自己。
But it just feels a little weird, because she can't pick it up or hold it or even really pet it. So it's kind of like, all the things-- all the reasons you'd want a guinea pig-- she can't have those.
但这感觉有点奇怪，因为她不能抱起它，甚至不能真正抚摸它。所以这就像是，所有你想要豚鼠的原因——她都无法拥有。
All a parent wants to do this time of year is make a nice Christmas for their kids. Linda does not even like pets, isn't crazy about having animals in the house. But the Three Kings brought a guinea pig.
父母在这个节日里想做的只是为孩子创造一个美好的圣诞节。琳达甚至不喜欢宠物，也不太热衷于在家里养动物。但三位国王还是带来了一只豚鼠。
The Three Kings is-- they do test. They have tested me. They test parents, I think.
三位国王——他们在考验。他们考验过我。我想，他们是在考验父母。
And not just parents. Linda asked Pirecua on tape, did the Three Kings know she was allergic when they brought her that gift? Pirecua told her she had never even considered the question.
不仅是父母。琳达在录音中问皮雷库亚，当三位国王给她带来那份礼物时，他们知道她会过敏吗？皮雷库亚告诉她，她甚至从未考虑过这个问题。
But aren't they supposed to be [SPANISH], like, wise men? If they did know that you were going to be allergic to Luna, why do you think they still brought her for you?
但是他们不是[西班牙语]，也就是智者吗？如果他们真的知道你会对露娜过敏，你觉得为什么他们还是把它带给你了？
Well, they would probably also know that I would love her even if I did have allergies.
嗯，他们可能也知道，即使我有过敏症，我也会爱它。
And the Three Wise Men made the right call. Today on our radio program, this Christmas holiday weekend, we have stories of parents and others trying to make the holiday incredible for the people that they love, going to great and ridiculous lengths involving live animals, a deer, a sled, ancient reindeer bones, which lead only, sometimes, to the most magical Christmases. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
三位智者做出了正确的决定。今天在我们的广播节目中，在这个圣诞假期周末，我们将讲述父母和其他人努力为他们所爱的人打造美好节日的故事，不惜采取伟大而荒唐的手段，涉及活的动物、鹿、雪橇、古老的驯鹿骨头，这些有时只会带来最神奇的圣诞节。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
Act One, Christmas in 3D. We all learn, at some point, that our parents make mistakes, and that can even-- and I know this will be a shock-- make them when they are trying their hardest at Christmas. Maya Gurantz tells the story. A quick warning for people listening with young children, this is a story about one family's Santa Claus traditions which may not be the same as yours. Also, I should say, today's show is a rerun from a few years back, so everybody who you're hearing in the story is just a bit older now. Anyway, here's Maya.
第一幕，3D圣诞节。我们在某个时刻都会意识到，父母也会犯错，甚至——我知道这会让人震惊——当他们在圣诞节尽最大努力时，也会犯错。玛雅·古兰茨讲述了这个故事。给带小孩听节目的听众提个醒，这是一个关于一个家庭圣诞老人传统的故事，可能和你们的不一样。另外，我应该说，今天的节目是几年前的重播，所以你在故事中听到的每个人现在都大了一些。总之，有请玛雅。
My friend Colin Mutchler is 36. And to this day, he talks about his Christmases as a kid. That's because his parents were determined to make the magic of Christmas come alive for their three kids-- Colin, Adam, and Erica. But they went further than any parents I know. They wanted it to be real-- really real. This wasn't an airbrushed "ho, ho, ho" Christmas but a darker, grittier one, like that one year when Colin was seven and his dad sent him to the garage for some firewood.
我的朋友科林·穆奇勒36岁了。直到今天，他还会谈论他小时候的圣诞节。那是因为他的父母决心为他们的三个孩子——科林、亚当和埃里卡——让圣诞节的魔力活起来。但他们比我认识的任何父母都走得更远。他们想让它变得真实——非常真实。这不是那种精修过的“吼吼吼”的圣诞节，而是一个更黑暗、更粗犷的圣诞节，就像科林七岁那年，他爸爸让他去车库拿些木柴。
And I heard some bells, and it freaked me out. And so I ran inside. And I was like, oh, my god, you guys, like I swear, I heard some bells. And my dad was like, no way. Really? And so I went-- we went back slowly outside. And basically, we found this older man.
我听到了一些铃铛声，这把我吓坏了。所以我跑进屋里。我说，天哪，你们听，我发誓，我听到了一些铃铛声。我爸爸说，不可能。真的吗？于是我们慢慢地回到了外面。基本上，我们发现了这个老头。
Colin's younger brother Adam was there, too.
科林的弟弟亚当也在那里。
This man had fallen in the backyard and slipped on the ice. But I was so young that it was like, who was this crazy man in our backyard? And I sort of-- are you OK? Are you OK? And they brought him inside.
这个人摔倒在后院，滑倒在冰上。但我当时太小了，感觉就像，这个出现在我们后院的疯老头是谁？我有点——你还好吗？你还好吗？然后他们把他带进了屋。
He was wearing a very old, rundown, weathered jacket. He said he had windburn.
他穿着一件非常旧的、破旧的、饱经风霜的夹克。他说他被风冻伤了。
And could you dim the lights? I've got snow blindness from the time in the North Pole, and there's a certain amount of glare that I can't deal with. So we dimmed the lights. He talked in a very soft-spoken-- not a whisper, but where he talked quietly enough that the whole room was silent, and you had to lean in. And it was that weird, intimate-- you're just immersed in whatever he was saying. And he basically said, I'm Kris Kringle.
你能把灯光调暗吗？我在北极时得了雪盲症，我无法忍受那种强光。所以我们调暗了灯光。他用一种非常轻柔的声音说话——不是耳语，但他说话的声音足够轻，整个房间都安静下来，你必须凑近去听。那是一种奇怪的、亲密的氛围——你完全沉浸在他所说的任何事情中。他基本上说，我是克里斯·克林格。
Adam was four, and he says this is his earliest memory of Christmas. All the Mutchler kids have memories like this, probably because they talked about it all the time when they were little. Colin and Adam didn't think there was just one Santa Claus living at the North Pole. The Mutchler family had their own mythology with its own logic. There wasn't just one Santa, but a network of Santas all working together as Christmas helpers. Kris Kringle was just one of them-- a working-man Santa. And just like a guy on a night shift from hell, he was exhausted.
亚当当时四岁，他说这是他关于圣诞节最早的记忆。所有穆奇勒家的孩子都有这样的记忆，可能是因为他们小时候经常谈论这些。科林和亚当不认为只有一个圣诞老人住在北极。穆奇勒一家有他们自己的神话和逻辑。不仅仅有一个圣诞老人，而是一个由圣诞老人组成的网络，大家一起作为圣诞助手工作。克里斯·克林格只是其中之一——一个干活的圣诞老人。就像一个从地狱来的夜班工人，他精疲力竭。
We were almost helping him. The dynamic was such that it was like, he was in a rough place, and we were trying to help him. And so I think we talked with him for a bit and then put him on his way.
我们甚至在帮助他。当时的情况是，他处于困境中，而我们正在努力帮助他。所以我想我们和他谈了一会儿，然后送他上路了。
Visitors like Kris appeared every couple of years or so in the band of woods dividing their house in Harrington Park, New Jersey, from a nearby golf course. Never the same guy, never in exactly the same place. They'd be disheveled, bearded, and hoarse-voiced, abandoned by their skittish and surprisingly losable reindeer, and searching for the Mutchlers, whose home address they never quite figured out.
像克里斯这样的访客每隔几年就会出现在他们家和附近高尔夫球场之间的一片树林里。从来不是同一个人，也从不在同一个地方。他们总是衣衫褴褛、留着胡子、声音嘶哑，被他们那些胆小、容易走失的驯鹿遗弃，在寻找穆奇勒一家，但他们从没弄清楚过穆奇勒家的确切地址。
The Mutchlers also had a family elf, Jeko, who the kids never saw but who apparently lived in the attic for a few weeks before Christmas. The kids would hear noises coming from upstairs-- hammering, walking. And when Christmas was over, they'd find wood scraps in the attic from the gifts he'd made for them, proof that Jeko had been there.
穆奇勒家还有一个家庭精灵杰科，孩子们从未见过，但他显然在圣诞节前几周住在阁楼里。孩子们会听到楼上传来的声音——敲击声、走动声。当圣诞节结束时，他们会在阁楼里发现杰科为他们制作礼物的木屑，证明杰科确实来过。
Both their father and grandfather grew up with Jeko. Their grandfather especially loved to tell scary stories about how mean Jeko could be. And so every Christmas, the family spent hours combing over the details of Jeko and their visitors, comparing them to previous Christmases, anticipating the next.
他们的父亲和祖父都是听着杰科的故事长大的。他们的祖父特别喜欢讲杰科有多么刻薄的可怕故事。所以每年圣诞节，全家人都要花几个小时仔细研究关于杰科和访客的细节，与往年的圣诞节进行比较，并期待下一个圣诞节。
When you ask the Mutchler kids which Christmas visitor was the one who outdid the rest, there's no question-- Christmas Eve, 1984. Colin was eight. Adam was five. Erica was two. The family was out taking their usual walk. And on this night, they went down to the golf course. It was foggy and dark. Here's Adam.
当你问穆奇勒家的孩子哪一个圣诞访客最出色时，毫无疑问——1984年的平安夜。科林八岁。亚当五岁。埃里卡两岁。全家人正在散步。那天晚上，他们去了高尔夫球场。天色昏暗，雾气蒙蒙。亚当说。
And then in the distance, we see this silhouette of a shadow scampering from tree to tree-- and it's a golf course. It's an open, wide spaces-- and looking like it doesn't-- they don't want us to know that they're there. And my dad says, look, let's go find out who that is. And so we start walking faster to try to catch up with this guy.
然后在远处，我们看到了一个影子在树与树之间窜动——这是一个高尔夫球场。这是一个开阔的空间——看起来他们不想让我们知道他们在那里。我爸爸说，看，我们去看看那是谁。所以我们开始加快脚步试图追上那个人。
When we come upon him, he's in this very worn, dirty Santa Claus suit that's this greenish-brown tint. And he introduces himself as Klaus Hoffer. And he's one of many-- the Santa Claus incarnations. Then he goes into a full explanation, but he definitely explains that-- I think we mentioned Kris Kringle. And it's like, oh, yeah. I know Kris.
当我们遇到他时，他穿着一件非常破旧、肮脏的圣诞老人套装，带着一种微绿棕色。他自我介绍说他是克劳斯·霍弗。他是众多圣诞老人化身中的一个。然后他开始进行完整的解释，但他确实解释说——我想我们提到了克里斯·克林格。他说，哦，是的。我认识克里斯。
Klaus had a worn sack and began pulling out presents.
克劳斯有一个破旧的麻袋，开始拿出礼物。
But the presents were very odd. There was vegetables, a head of broccoli, an onion. And then he also, I think, gave us some bones. And that comes to the most important thing, is he broke out one bone in particular. And he said, this is one of the bones from the original Rudolph. I use it to call the reindeer.
但这些礼物非常奇怪。有蔬菜，一个西兰花，一个洋葱。然后我想他还给了我们一些骨头。这是最重要的一点，他拿出了其中一根特别的骨头。他说，这是原版鲁道夫的骨头之一。我用它来召唤驯鹿。
Again, here's Colin and their sister Erica.
再说一次，这是科林和他们的妹妹埃里卡。
And literally, when he broke out bones and started blowing on them, we were like, oh my god. This is crazy.
当他拿出骨头并开始对着它们吹气时，我们简直惊呆了。天哪。这太疯狂了。
It made no noise. We couldn't hear it. But he said it was a pitch that only the reindeer could hear.
它没有发出任何声音。我们听不见。但他说是只有驯鹿才能听到的音调。
And when he talked about Rudolph, it wasn't like (SINGING) Rudolph, the Red-Nosed Reindeer. It was like he was honoring the history of Rudolph as some reindeer that they all honored. And the fact that he had some of these bones of Rudolph and was using them to call to the reindeer just-- it made sense to us. It was like, that makes sense.
当他谈论鲁道夫时，不像（唱歌）“鲁道夫，红鼻子驯鹿”。他是在以尊重鲁道夫的历史，仿佛他们都尊重那只驯鹿。他拥有鲁道夫的骨头，并用它们来召唤驯鹿，这——这让我们觉得很有道理。就像，那讲得通。
The details were perfectly calibrated, as only people who know you as well as your parents can get just right. Here's Adam.
细节经过了完美的校准，只有像父母那样了解你的人才能做到恰到好处。这是亚当。
And that's when it got scary. He offered all the kids. And he said, I can only invite the kids, but do you guys want to come on the sleigh? Do you want to come to the North Pole with me? And we just sat there frozen. Wow. I could say, yes.
就在那时，事情变得可怕了。他邀请所有的孩子。他说，我只能邀请孩子们，但你们想坐雪橇吗？你们想跟我一起去北极吗？我们只是坐在那里僵住了。哇。我可以答应说，好。
The answer is no. The truth is, when some old man that you just met in the dark golf course on Christmas Eve actually asks me and my brother and my sister if we want to go with him somewhere that we have no idea-- while that might be the coolest thing of all time, it might also be the end of life as I know it.
答案是不。事实是，当一个你在平安夜的黑暗高尔夫球场刚认识的老头，真的问我和我的弟弟妹妹是否想跟他去一个我们根本不知道的地方时——虽然那可能是史上最酷的事情，但也可能是终结我生命的事情。
Again, Erica, who, remember, was two at the time.
还是埃里卡，记住，她当时才两岁。
And I remember screaming and not wanting to go. I was just terrified.
我记得我在尖叫，不想去。我当时被吓坏了。
Actually, that invitation to the North Pole? That never happened, at least not the way they remember it.
实际上，那个去北极的邀请？那从未发生过，至少不是他们记忆中的那样。
It's "Klus" not "Klaus"
是“Klus”而不是“Klaus”
Yeah, yeah, "Klas."
对，对，“Klas”。
"Klaus."
“Klaus”。
"Klas"
“Klas”
"Klus."
“Klus”。
This is a recording from that Christmas Eve in 1984. Erica, Adam, and Colin had just come back from meeting Klaus. On the recording, the kids seem happy and hopped up on adrenaline. They talk about Klaus, but in the entire recording, never mention any invitation to the North Pole. What you hear instead is the grandfather suggesting, how would you like it if he had asked you to the North Pole? Then their father Glenn jumps in.
这是1984年那个平安夜的录音。埃里卡、亚当和科林刚从遇见克劳斯回来。在录音中，孩子们看起来很高兴，肾上腺素飙升。他们谈论克劳斯，但在整个录音中，从未提到任何去北极的邀请。你听到的是祖父在建议，如果他邀请你们去北极，你们会怎么想？然后他们的父亲格伦插话了。
Well, look. You guys could have asked, and he would've taken you. I had a feeling he was going to-- he would be willing to take somebody for a short trip.
嗯，看。你们本来可以问的，他会带你们去的。我有一种感觉他会——他愿意带某人去进行一次短途旅行。
They were scared. That's--
他们被吓到了。那是——
They were scared--
他们被吓到了——
I was scared, too.
我也被吓到了。
I was--
我——
Behold, the power of suggestion.
瞧，这就是心理暗示的力量。
Grandma.
祖母。
That's how it seemed like a lot of it worked-- the Mutchler parents making suggestions and adding details, and then retelling it all year after year. Christmas was a big topic of conversation, and the Mutchler parents encouraged their kids with the most exciting versions of what happened on those nights, to the point where the stories gained an unstoppable momentum.
这似乎就是很多事情运作的方式——穆奇勒父母给出建议并添加细节，然后年复一年地重述。圣诞节是一个很大的话题，穆奇勒父母用最令人兴奋的版本鼓励他们的孩子，以至于这些故事产生了不可阻挡的势头。
As the Mutchler kids got older, things, as they do, changed. Each of the kids dealt with it differently. Both Colin and Erica say they knew, at a certain point, to not talk about Jeko and the others to people outside their closest circles. But Adam didn't get that at all. Adam loved to tell a good story. He couldn't not tell this one. And he believed wholeheartedly in his experiences, even as a teenager in public school in New Jersey. And it had consequences.
随着穆奇勒家的孩子长大，事情也随之改变。每个孩子处理它的方式都不同。科林和埃里卡都说，他们在某个时候就知道，不要和最亲密圈子以外的人谈论杰科和蔼其他人。但亚当根本没意识到这一点。亚当喜欢讲好故事。他不能不讲这个。甚至作为一个在新泽西州公立学校上学的青少年，他依然全心全意地相信他的经历。而这带来了后果。
When Adam was in fifth grade, he defended his stories about Klaus and Kris and the rest in front of his whole class. It got so confrontational, with Adam telling the whole group how wrong they were, that the teacher ended up calling Adam's parents, telling them it had almost started a fight, and asking them to please tell Adam to stop talking about it. Adam remembers many arguments like this well into middle school. People would call him an idiot or weird, and he would insist that these events were true. He was there. It was real. You guys are crazy, not me.
当亚当上五年级时，他在全班同学面前捍卫关于克劳斯、克里斯和其他人的故事。这变得非常有对抗性，亚当告诉整个小组他们有多么错误，以至于老师最终打电话给亚当的父母，说这差点引发了一场打架，并请求他们请亚当停止谈论这件事。亚当记得很多这样的争论，直到中学。人们会叫他白痴或怪胎，而他会坚持认为这些事件是真实的。他在场。那是真的。你们这些人才疯了，不是我。
The next year, sixth grade, Adam was at his grandparents' house at Christmastime when his great aunt Blanche made some offhanded comment about which uncle played what part what year back when they were kids. Adam walked himself through the logic of what she was saying. And he knew right then that his parents had lied to him.
第二年，六年级，亚当在圣诞节期间在祖父母家，当时他的姑祖母布兰奇随口评论说，当他们还是孩子时，哪个叔叔哪一年扮演了什么角色。亚当顺着她说的话推导了逻辑。他当时就知道他的父母对他撒了谎。
Not only did they lie to me, it was-- 13 years old, I had to deal with that as a social thing that I had done. I had defended myself and told these stories.
他们不仅对我撒了谎，而且——13岁，我必须处理我所做的一件社交事情。我捍卫了自己并讲了这些故事。
In front of lots of people.
在很多人面前。
Lots of people. And to know that my parents were responsible for allowing me to perpetuate something that made me a liar and a laughingstock.
很多人。而且知道我的父母应对让我 perpetrate（传播）让我变成一个骗子和笑柄的事情负责。
You were embarrassed.
你很尴尬。
I was very embarrassed.
我非常尴尬。
Adam felt betrayed and was angry about it for years. One year, he came home from college and accused his parents for being the reason he couldn't trust anyone enough to have a serious girlfriend-- not too different from the sorts of speeches lots of kids make to their parents at that age, except it was about Santa. Even he admits it was pretty extreme.
亚当感到被背叛了，并因此愤怒了多年。有一年，他从大学回家，指责他的父母是他无法信任任何人以至于拥有认真女朋友的原因——这和很多孩子在那个年龄对父母说的话没什么不同，除了它是关于圣诞老人的。即使他承认这也相当极端。
I think it was--
我想是——
So this one thing made you feel like you couldn't trust your parents even though they were trustworthy parents.
所以这一件事让你觉得你无法信任你的父母，尽管他们是值得信赖的父母。
Well, for me, it was the intricacy and the planning of, like, you spent seven years, or 10 years, perpetrating a lie that was so deep and complex, whether it was hiring people, vintage suits, hunting people through the golf course and through the woods. What are you, insane? This is diabolical. For me, there was a big breakdown in the way I trusted people in my life that actually-- I think it carried on into my adult life. And even to this day, I don't 100% trust anyone anymore.
对我来说，是这种复杂性和计划性，比如，你花了七年或十年，策划了一个如此深沉和复杂的谎言，无论是雇用人员、购买复古服装、在高尔夫球场和树林里寻找人员。你们疯了吗？这太邪恶了。对我来说，我信任我生命中的人的方式发生了巨大的崩溃，这实际上——我认为它延续到了我的成年生活。即使到今天，我也不再100%信任任何人了。
Do you feel like it made you cynical?
你觉得这让你变得愤世嫉俗了吗？
A little bit. Yeah, a little bit.
有一点。是的，有一点。
Adam is 33 and can laugh about most of this now. He sees what was great about what his parents did at Christmas. But he won't be doing anything like it, he says, when he has his own kids. And because of the way he reacted as a teenager, these childhood Christmases are still a touchy subject in his family. When they talk about it, everybody's careful to keep things upbeat. I wondered if the parents had any regrets for how they handled it, so I went to meet the Mutchlers.
亚当33岁了，现在可以对这些事一笑置之了。他看到了父母在圣诞节所做的事情伟大之处。但他表示，当他有自己的孩子时，他不会做类似的事情。由于他作为青少年的反应，这些童年的圣诞节仍然是他家庭中一个敏感的话题。当他们谈论它时，每个人都很小心地保持气氛轻松。我很好奇父母是否对他们处理这件事的方式感到后悔，所以我去见了穆奇勒一家。
[FOOTSTEPS]
[脚步声]
Oh, you know my two boys--
哦，你知道我的两个儿子——
I do.
我知道。
--huh?
——是吧？
I do. And--
我知道。而且——
Glenn and Laurie Mutchler live on a beautiful, quiet street. It's the kind of place where deer wander through the yards. A giant wreath hangs off the top of the Mutchler's beige clapboard house. Christmas lights twinkle inside and outside.
格伦和劳里·穆奇勒住在一条美丽、安静的街道上。那是一个鹿会在院子里漫步的地方。一个巨大的花环挂在穆奇勒家米色护墙板房子的顶部。圣诞灯在室内和室外闪烁。
We sit in the living room, where the mantle has been turned into an altar crowded with an assortment of spiritual icons-- Buddhas, Vishnu, a ceramic bust of Jesus, and two different portraits of Jerry Garcia. I was a hippie and did the whole nine yards, Glenn told me, on the West Coast in the '70s, though he doesn't like the word "hippie"-- thinks it's come to connote laziness, and he's anything but.
我们坐在客厅里，壁炉架变成了一个祭坛，上面挤满了各种精神偶像——佛像、毗湿奴、耶稣的陶瓷半身像，以及两张杰瑞·加西亚的画像。格伦告诉我，我在70年代的西海岸当过嬉皮士，做了所有那套，虽然他不喜欢“嬉皮士”这个词——认为它开始暗示懒惰，而他绝不是懒人。
And who knows--
谁知道呢——
We started talking about the elaborate Christmases the Mutchlers used to have for their kids, and I asked Laurie.
我们开始谈论穆奇勒一家过去为孩子们举办的精致圣诞节，我问劳里。
How did you get roped into all of this, Laurie?
你是怎么被卷入这一切的，劳里？
Well, I-- as we were talking about this--
嗯，我——当我们谈论这个时——
That's a cynic.
那是个愤世嫉俗的人。
I'm going to talk--
我要说——
Listen to this.
听这个。
No, no, no. I want to talk--
不，不，不。我想说——
Roped in.
被卷入。
No, no, no--
不，不，不——
I don't know if you caught that, but he called me a cynic.
我不知道你是否听到了，但他叫我愤世嫉俗。
I'm not a cynic. We're just so excited about how you pulled this off.
我不是愤世嫉俗。我们只是对你是如何完成这些壮举感到非常兴奋。
There is no pulling off. Something happened. People had an experience. And then you have this thought called "somebody pulled something off."
没有完成什么。事情发生了。人们有了经历。然后你有了这个想法，叫“有人完成了什么”。
I wasn't prepared for this. Decades after these Christmases, Glenn was refusing to admit he had anything to do with creating them.
我没准备好迎接这个。在这些圣诞节过去几十年后，格伦拒绝承认他和创造它们有任何关系。
So the conjecture and all that stuff would really undermine the magic. In fact, all the details-- the, as you call them, the mechanics or as called, how'd you pull it off? It happened. That's the magic, and that's the secret.
所以推测和所有那些东西真的会破坏魔力。事实上，所有的细节——你所说的机制，或者被称作，你怎么做到的？它发生了。这就是魔力，这就是秘密。
We went back and forth about this for more than 10 minutes. Here's my producer Robin having a go at it.
我们在这件事上反复谈了十多分钟。这是我的制片人罗宾在尝试。
It would help to know if that's just an impossible thing for us to ask, because we have some questions about how it works, and I just would-- I'm wondering if we could--
如果我们问这是否是不可能的事情，那会有所帮助，因为我们对它是如何运作的有疑问，我只是——我想知道我们是否可以——
Well, you could make something up. You could hypothesize. But that's you, because the magic is too powerful. And you want to go--
嗯，你可以编造一些东西。你可以假设。但那是你，因为魔力太强大了。而你想去——
And did they have any regrets about when their kids learned the truth? I asked Glenn and Laurie about the time that Adam fought with his fifth grade class about the Mutchler Christmas stories. It seemed like it would have been a perfect moment to come clean.
他们是否对孩子得知真相的时候感到后悔？我问格伦和劳里关于亚当和五年级同学争论穆奇勒圣诞故事的那次。这看起来是一个完美交代真相的时刻。
They said after the school called them, they did talk to Adam, but they didn't tell him he was wrong. They didn't tell him the truth. If anything, they encouraged him to believe the stories were real, saying, I was there. You were there. Their only parental advice was, be more private about it. Stop talking about it at school. Though, Laurie did come to worry that they should have handled it differently.
他们说在学校打电话给他们后，他们确实和亚当谈过，但他们没有告诉他他错了。他们没有告诉他真相。如果有的话，他们鼓励他相信故事是真实的，说，我当时就在场。你当时就在场。他们唯一的父母建议是，对此更保密一些。不要在学校谈论它。虽然，劳里确实开始担心他们应该以不同的方式处理这件事。
I think, for me, I did really start to question whether we should be making such a big deal about it. And I wanted to stop doing it. It definitely happened, in my mind. I did. And as you can tell, Glenn's a very powerful force in our family. And he's a very powerful for it. Yeah, he is. And even before this interview, it was like, you set up the ground rules about how we were going to have the interview. They're going to ask us, and we're not going to tell, right?
我想，对我来说，我真的开始质疑我们是否应该对此大惊小怪。我想停止这样做。在我的脑海中，它确实发生了。我做了。而且你可以看出，格伦在我们家里是一个非常有影响力的力量。他非常有影响力。是的，他是。甚至在这次采访之前，就像是，你设定了我们将如何进行采访的规则。他们会问我们，我们不会说，对吧？
Both Glenn and Laurie say they tried to make it right for Adam. They had no idea how betrayed he felt until later. Laurie says for a while, she didn't know what to do.
格伦和劳里都说他们试图为亚当弥补。他们不知道他感到多么被背叛，直到后来。劳里说有一段时间，她不知道该怎么办。
We talked about it a lot. We talked about the magic and the wanting it to-- Adam, can you see-- can you find a place where you see where it all came from-- it all came from good. It didn't come from lying. It didn't come from tricking. We are not bad parents because we did that.
我们谈论了很多。我们谈论了魔力以及想要它——亚当，你能看到吗——你能找到一个地方，看到它都来自哪里吗——它都来自善意。它不是来自撒谎。它不是来自欺骗。我们不是坏父母，因为我们那样做了。
Finally, Laurie tells me this story. It's an important one for her. And before she starts, she says she knows Glenn doesn't want her to tell it. But that's not going to stop her. One Christmas Eve when Adam was in junior high school, Laurie went to his bedroom.
最后，劳里给我讲了这个故事。这对她来说很重要。在开始之前，她说她知道格伦不想让她说。但这不会阻止她。有一个平安夜，亚当上初中时，劳里去了他的卧室。
And I was giving him a goodnight kiss and hug and Merry Christmas. And he looked me straight in the eyes, and he said, you've got to tell me the truth. Your son is looking you right in the eyes, saying, you've got to tell me the truth. Were those rea-- did Santa really visit us? And in the back of my mind, it was Glenn's voice going, you never tell. You never tell. The magic. The magic. And I spewed all this magic. And it's the magic, and it's the spirit. And I went on and on.
我在给他晚安吻和拥抱，祝他圣诞快乐。他直视我的眼睛说，你必须告诉我真相。你的儿子直视着你的眼睛说，你必须告诉我真相。那些是真的吗——圣诞老人真的拜访过我们吗？在我的脑海深处，是格伦的声音说，永远不要说。永远不要说。魔力。魔力。我滔滔不绝地讲了所有这些魔力。它是魔力，它是精神。我滔滔不绝地讲个没完。
And he would not let it down. He just said, stop it. Don't talk about that stuff. Glenn talks about that stuff. You'll tell me the truth. Tell me the truth. And I don't even know what I exactly said, but I did let him know that it wasn't real. And we just cried, the two of us.
他不肯罢休。他只是说，停下。不要谈论那些东西。格伦谈论那些东西。你会告诉我真相。告诉我真相。我甚至不知道我具体说了什么，但我确实让他知道那不是真的。我们只是哭了，我们俩。
[SOBBING] And it was really sad. Because then, over the years, he would-- when he did say, later-- when he said, I can't believe that that was a parenting decision that you made, that you went to that extreme, he just-- it just hurt him. And it was so weird because Colin and Erica had taken the same wonderful experience and held it as a wonderful experience, no matter what happened or what was real. They could hold it as just a magical, wonderful moment. And he, somehow, couldn't. And it made me really sad.
[抽泣] 那真的很令人难过。因为后来，这些年来，他会——当他后来确实说时——当他说，我不敢相信那是你做的父母决定，你走到了那个极端，这只是——它只是伤害了他。这太奇怪了，因为科林和埃里卡接受了同样的精彩经历，并将其作为一次精彩的经历，无论发生了什么或什么是真实的。他们可以将它作为一次充满魔力的、美妙的时刻。而他，以某种方式，做不到。这让我感到非常难过。
Glenn understands that something went wrong with Adam.
格伦明白亚当身上出了些问题。
My experiences like this with kids-- you do the best you can. And sometimes, you do the right thing, and maybe you do the wrong thing when you thought you did the right thing. There's a time when the kids are young, and you experience the magic through them. And it's just so special to be around young kids and to be in that-- maybe you cheat a little bit, and you become-- you're living through them.
我和孩子们有过这样的经历——你尽你所能。有时，你做了正确的事，而当你以为你做了正确的事时，也许你做了错误的事。当孩子们还小的时候，你会通过他们体验魔力。在那附近真的太特别了，和年幼的孩子在一起，在那——也许你作弊了一点点，然后你变成了——你通过他们活着。
[FOOTSTEPS]
[脚步声]
Glenn had been eager, from the moment we arrived at his house, to take us on a tour of Christmas past. And after our interview, Glenn and Laurie head out with us for a walk. We go up the street, passed through some trees, and onto the golf course.
从我们到达他家那一刻起，格伦就急于带我们参观过去的圣诞节。采访结束后，格伦和劳里和我们一起出去散步。我们沿着街道往上走，穿过一些树林，来到高尔夫球场。
It was darker than I had imagined it would be, barely illuminated by the ambient orange of nearby street lights. Mist clung to the rolling expanse of grass. Then Glenn does what he's clearly been itching to do all night-- gives us the play-by-play from his finest hour, the night Klaus Hoffer came to visit.
它比我想象的要暗，几乎被附近路灯发出的环境橙色光照亮。薄雾粘在起伏的草地上。然后格伦做了他整晚都跃跃欲试的事情——给我们从他最光辉的时刻开始的逐场直播，那个克劳斯·霍弗来访的夜晚。
Get away! Stay away! Who is it? I'm looking for the Mucklers. And then the kids would say, no, the Mutchlers?
走开！离远点！是谁？我在找穆奇勒一家。然后孩子们会说，不，是穆奇勒一家吗？
Glenn hunches down and reenacts Klaus Hoffer's disappearance into the distance.
格伦躬着身子，重现了克劳斯·霍弗消失在远处的场景。
It's kind of like this and like this and like this and like this.
它有点像这样，这样，这样，这样。
He lopes along. He's happy. Magic is Glenn's strength--
他轻快地跑着。他很高兴。魔力是格伦的强项——
--into the darkness--
——进入黑暗——
--and his blind spot.
——也是他的盲点。
And we're all standing there going, like, oh, my god. Did that really happen? It was like that. It was perfect. It was perfect.
然后我们都站在那里说，天哪。那真的发生过吗？就像那样。它是完美的。它是完美的。
Maya Gurantz. She's the co-host of the culture and politics podcast The Sauce. Coming up, typecast. Typecast-- do you hear me-- as a reindeer in a Christmas pageant, the tail-twitching injustice of it. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues
玛雅·古兰茨。她是文化和政治播客《The Sauce》的联合主持人。接下来，类型化。类型化——你听到了吗——作为圣诞表演中的驯鹿，那种甩尾的不公正。那将在片刻之后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show for the holidays, "Lights, Camera, Christmas"-- stories of people trying to throw a nice Christmas for those they love. We've arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Deer in the Footlights. So Connie grew up on this ranch outside of a little town in Utah called Woodruff. And maybe you've never been to Woodruff.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们的节目当然会选择一个主题，带给你关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节日节目，“灯光，摄像，圣诞节”——讲述人们试图为他们所爱的人举办一个美好圣诞节的故事。我们进入了节目的第二幕，第二幕，灯光下的鹿。康妮在犹他州伍德拉夫一个小镇外的一个牧场长大。也许你从未去过伍德拉夫。
It's-- let me tell you about it. You'll have to edit this now, because I'm going to say it like I always say it.
它是——让我告诉你。你现在必须编辑一下，因为我会像我平时说的那样说。
OK.
好的。
You go through town. There's a church on the right. There's an old school on the left. You get down to the crossroads, and there's a half-assed store on one side and the post office on the other side.
你穿过小镇。右边有一座教堂。左边有一所旧学校。你走到十字路口，一边有一家半吊子商店，另一边是邮局。
That's it-- the whole town. Maybe 250 people, she says. Maybe fewer. And the basic facts of her childhood are the kinds of things that lots of little girls only read about in storybooks. During the summer, Connie and her two sisters, they would get up. They'd have some food. And they would spend the whole day, she says, on their own horses, riding far and wide together.
就是这样——整个镇子。她说也许250人。也许更少。她童年的基本事实是很多小女孩只在故事书里读到的那种。夏天，康妮和她的两个姐妹会起床。她们会吃些东西。她说，她们会整天骑着自己的马，一起走得很远。
And when they were little, they got a baby deer-- a baby deer of their very own-- who ended up a part of Christmas at their elementary school in a way that, I think, probably very rarely happens with deers and elementary schools and Christmases.
当她们小的时候，她们得到了一只小鹿——一只她们自己的小鹿——它最终以一种我想可能在鹿、小学和圣诞节之间很少发生的方式，成为了她们小学圣诞节的一部分。
So the story that I want you to tell is, I want to know how a deer ended up on the stage as part of your school's Christmas pageant when you were a kid. And I guess you should explain how you even ended up with a deer in the first place. Do you remember when you first saw the deer?
所以我想要你讲的故事是，我想知道当你还是个孩子的时候，一只鹿是如何在学校圣诞表演中登上舞台的。我想你应该解释一下你们是怎么得到一只鹿的。你记得你第一次见到那只鹿的时候吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. We were all on our horses, and there was a doe that had just had a baby. It was, I'd say, maybe two or three days old. Well, we chased the doe off and took the deer-- took the fawn.
哦，是的。是的。我们都骑在马上，有一只母鹿刚刚生了一个宝宝。我想，也许两三天大。嗯，我们把母鹿赶走，带走了鹿——带走了小鹿。
Did you run off the mom hoping to get the baby?
你是赶走了妈妈希望能得到宝宝吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
You did?
真的吗？
Yeah. Oh, yeah, and brought it home. Let me tell you what. We never done it again, because my dad was really pissed-- just livid. He lit into us like you can't believe.
是的。哦，是的，并把它带回家。让我告诉你。我们再也没这样做过，因为我爸爸真的气疯了——简直火冒三丈。他像你无法相信的那样教训了我们。
And what was his argument? What was the problem with bringing in this deer?
他的论点是什么？带这只鹿来有什么问题？
Nature should be left to nature. Why did we want to run that deer off-- that mother-- when she was perfectly capable of raising this fawn and taking care of it? Why did we-- what give us the right to do with it, to take Mother Nature's course away from her.
大自然应该留给大自然。我们为什么要赶走那只鹿——那个妈妈——当她完全有能力抚养这只小鹿并照顾它时？为什么我们——什么给了我们权利去那样做，剥夺了大自然的进程。
How big is a fawn when it's that little? Is it the size of a big dog?
小鹿那么小的时候有多大？它有大狗那么大吗？
Oh--
哦——
I'm trying to picture.
我在尝试想象。
Yeah, it'd be about the size of a big dog-- maybe not a real big dog. And they're light. It couldn't have weighed any more than, I'm going to say, 25, 35 pounds. And we put it on our horses-- put it across the saddle and packed it back to the house. Oh, we was tickled. We really thought we'd done something good.
是的，它大约有一只大狗那么大——也许不是特别大的狗。它们很轻。它肯定不会超过，我要说，25到35磅。我们把它放在马上——横放在马鞍上，把它运回屋里。哦，我们真高兴。我们真的以为我们做了一件好事。
And so you raised it. How do you feed it?
所以你们抚养了它。你们怎么喂它？
You put a nipple-- a lamb nipple-- on a pop bottle-- on the end of a pop bottle. And they suck it. And so we raised him that summer. And then, of course, he lost his spots.
你把一个奶嘴——一个羊奶嘴——放在汽水瓶上——放在汽水瓶的末端。它们会吸吮它。所以我们那个夏天抚养了它。然后，当然，它身上的斑点消失了。
Did you give it a name?
你们给它取名字了吗？
Well, we called him Bambi.
嗯，我们叫它斑比。
Very original. OK.
非常有创意。好的。
Yeah, very original.
是的，非常有创意。
So was he a good pet?
所以它是一只好的宠物吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. He was a lot of fun. We never had a collar or anything on him, never did break him to lead. We just put our hands on his-- what we call their withers, where their neck goes right into their shoulders. And he'd walk by you. So we could walk him-- damn near any place we wanted to go, he'd go.
哦，是的。是的。它很有趣。我们从未给它戴项圈之类的，也从未训练它去领路。我们只是把手放在它的——我们称之为鬐甲的地方，脖子连接肩膀的地方。它会走在你旁边。所以我们可以带它走——几乎我们想去的任何地方，它都会去。
So that year, the year we got him-- that was the year that they done the play. And they took a balloon, and blowed it up about the size of a golf ball, and put it on his nose. And he stood there with this red thing on his nose all during the play.
那一年，我们得到它的那一年——那是他们演出那场戏的一年。他们拿了一个气球，吹到大约高尔夫球那么大，放在它的鼻子上。整个演出过程中，它都站着，鼻子上有那个红色的东西。
Hmm.
嗯。
And if I remember right, the story just, more or less, centered around Santa Claus being sad because he couldn't get around.
如果我没记错的话，故事更多或更少是以圣诞老人感到难过因为他无法四处走动为中心。
Well, it sounds like "Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer," where his nose is what guides them. The light from his nose is what guides them to where they need to go.
嗯，听起来像是“红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫”，它的鼻子是引导它们的东西。它鼻子发出的光是引导它们去需要去的地方的东西。
I think so. I think that's what it was. And I can remember that the hall was just crowded. Everybody knew that deer was going to be in there, and so everybody come to watch it.
我想是这样。我想就是那样。我记得大厅里挤满了人。每个人都知道那只鹿会在那里，所以每个人都来看它。
Oh, really? He was the star attraction of the show? He brought the crowd?
哦，真的吗？它是演出的明星吸引力？它带来了人群？
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. They still talk about that play. I don't think they ever did top that play. How could you?
哦，是的。哦，是的。他们现在还在谈论那场戏。我觉得他们从来没有超越那场戏。怎么可能呢？
Was he on stage for most of the show?
演出大部分时间它都在台上吗？
Oh, he was on stage for the whole show. He probably stood there for a good two hours. So we spent the whole night standing there by the deer. He'd look out in the crowd and look everybody over. You could see his ears moving back and forth. But we'd pet him or scratch him on the neck.
哦，整个演出它都在台上。它可能站了足足两个小时。所以我们整晚都站在鹿旁边。它会看向人群，审视每个人。你可以看到它的耳朵来回摆动。但我们会抚摸它或挠它的脖子。
What did he do when they applauded? I would think that for an animal that must have been so strange-- the noise that would come from that.
当人们鼓掌时它做了什么？我会想，对于一只动物来说那一定非常奇怪——那种噪音会从那里传来。
Nothing. He stood there. That's when he'd wiggle his tail. And his ears would go back and forth.
什么也没做。它就站在那里。那是它摆动尾巴的时候。它的耳朵会来回动。
Now, your dad, who had been against bringing in a wild animal the whole time, do you remember what his reaction was to the play?
现在，你爸爸，一直反对带一只野生动物进来的人，你记得他对这场戏的反应吗？
I can remember him saying that it was really a nice play and he was glad that the deer had a part in it. But I remember when we started to brand, we just begged Dad to let us castrate him, and he wouldn't do it. And as a kid, I just-- oh, I was upset.
我记得他说那真是一场不错的戏，他很高兴那只鹿在其中扮演了一个角色。但我记得当我们开始烙印时，我们只是恳求爸爸让我们阉割它，但他不肯。作为一个孩子，我只是——哦，我很难过。
Wait, why did you want your dad to castrate him?
等等，你为什么要让你爸爸阉割它？
So he'd stay home. It's just like a dog. You take a dog, and if you've got a male dog, and you don't want that dog to go-- I call it tramping-- all over the countryside, you castrate him. We knew that if Dad had let us castrate him, we would have had him forever. But no. So he wouldn't let us castrate him.
这样它就会留在家里。就像狗一样。你带着一只狗，如果你有一只公狗，你不想让那只狗去——我称之为流浪——到处跑，你就会阉割它。我们知道如果爸爸让我们阉割它，我们就会永远拥有它。但不。所以他不让我们阉割它。
Over the next year, Bambi grew up, developed antlers. Connie and her sisters liked to touch the velvet on his antlers, she says. And Bambi started acting differently. Sometimes, he'd just wander away for days. And when hunting season rolled around, the girls begged their dad to lock up Bambi somewhere on their property. But their dad said, no, that wasn't right. And they didn't ask twice, she says.
第二年，斑比长大了，长出了鹿角。康妮和她的姐妹们喜欢触摸它鹿角上的天鹅绒，她说。斑比开始表现得不同了。有时，它会莫名其妙地消失几天。当狩猎季节来临时，女孩们恳求爸爸把斑比关在她们地盘的某个地方。但爸爸说，不，那样不对。她说，她们没有问第二次。
Fortunately, because it was a small town, and especially after the Christmas play, everybody in the valley there knew about Bambi. The girls would take him into town sometimes in a car. And people would come up to them on the street and pet him. And they took special precautions during hunting season so everybody would recognize him.
幸运的是，因为那是一个小镇，特别是在那场圣诞表演之后，山谷里的每个人都知道斑比。女孩们有时会开车带它进城。人们会走在街上走近她们并抚摸它。在狩猎季节，她们采取了特别的预防措施，以便每个人都能认出它。
We had a big red scarf on him. And then we had a sheep bell, which is just a little smaller than a cow bell. And we'd painted this sheep bell red. And then, of course, when fall came-- late fall-- why, he took off. And about 10 miles away, some guy, I guess they said-- I never did ever talk to the guy, but they said he drove right up to him and shot him.
我们给它系了一条大红围巾。然后我们有一个羊铃，比牛铃小一点。我们把这个羊铃漆成了红色。然后，当然，当秋天来临——深秋——为什么，它跑了。大约10英里外，有个家伙，我想他们说——我从未和那个家伙交谈过，但他们说他直接开车到它身边射杀了它。
Oh, the deer didn't even run away.
哦，那只鹿甚至没有跑开。
No, no. No, he wouldn't run because he was desensitized. He wasn't afraid of people.
不，不。不，它不会跑，因为它已经脱敏了。它不怕人。
When the deer was killed, what did your dad say?
当那只鹿被杀死时，你爸爸说了什么？
Just told us that that's just the way it was, and that's what we got for bringing him home. He told us then-- he said, that's what happens when you mess with Mother Nature.
只是告诉我们事情就是这样，这就是我们把它带回家的代价。他那时告诉我们——他说，这就是当你干扰大自然时会发生的事情。
Hmm.
嗯。
So I guess, you know, if there's a moral to the story, is you don't mess with something that's wild. You just leave it be.
所以我猜，你知道，如果这个故事有什么道德意义的话，那就是不要干涉野生的东西。你只需让它顺其自然。
Oh, really? Do you think your dad was right?
哦，真的吗？你觉得你爸爸是对的吗？
I think he was right. At the time, I didn't. But looking back on it now-- I'm still pissed at that guy that shot him.
我觉得他是对的。当时我不觉得。但现在回想起来——我仍然对那个射杀它的人感到愤怒。
Because you're sure that he knew him?
因为你确定他认识它？
Oh, sure, he did. He'd a had to have known. Well, in fact, I heard that he did-- that he knew. I hope he enjoyed eating him, the son of a bitch. You better edit that out. [SCOFFS]
哦，当然，他知道。他肯定知道。嗯，事实上，我听说他确实——他知道。我希望他喜欢吃它，那个混蛋。你最好把它编辑掉。[冷笑]
No, I'd like to leave that in. Is that OK?
不，我想保留那个。可以吗？
That's fine.
没问题。
OK.
好的。
No, that's fine.
不，没问题。
I just don't understand how he could shoot him knowing that he was your pet. Like he knew you guys, right?
我只是不明白他怎么能开枪打它，明知道它是你们的宠物。就像他认识你们一样，对吧？
Yeah, yeah. And thinking back, I would imagine he'd probably-- what, 19 years old? Smart-ass teenager is what he was. I can remember we cried. Mother cried. And Dad was pissed. He thought that was pretty low for somebody to do that to an animal, especially when he knew that it was ours.
是的，是的。回想起来，我会想象他可能——什么，19岁？他是个自以为是的青少年。我记得我们哭了。母亲哭了。爸爸很生气。他认为有人对一只动物那样做太卑鄙了，尤其是当他知道它是我们的时候。
Did you blame yourselves?
你责怪你自己吗？
Yes, I did. Yes. The end result would have probably been the same, but he probably would have lived-- he'd have probably got another year or two before he'd have got shot.
是的，我责怪。是的。最终结果可能是一样的，但他可能还会活着——他可能还会再活一两年才会被射杀。
You mean if you had left him with his mom?
你是说如果你们把它留给它妈妈？
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
是的。哦，是的。是的。
It's funny. I thought we were going to have a sweet little sentimental Christmas story here, but now I feel so sad.
真有趣。我以为我们会有一个甜蜜的小感伤圣诞故事，但现在我觉得好难过。
Yeah, it did end up sad. And you know, if I was you, and you was doing the story, I think maybe I'd take a little liberty with it and not burden kids with what happened to him.
是的，它最终确实很悲伤。你知道，如果我是你，你是讲故事的人，我想也许我会在这上面稍微自由发挥一下，不要让孩子们被它身上发生的事情所负担。
Really? How would you want it to end?
真的吗？你希望它怎么结束？
Oh, like it was just a really nice play.
哦，就像它只是一场非常好的戏一样。
And not tell anything that happens afterwards.
并且不要说后来发生的任何事情。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
But then if you do that version of the story, then in the argument between you guys and your dad, you win, because everything works out happily ever after.
但如果你那样讲故事，那么在你们和你们爸爸的争论中，你们赢了，因为一切都幸福地结束了。
Well, I think at Christmastime, maybe we should win.
嗯，我觉得在圣诞节期间，也许我们应该赢。
All right. Well, let's do take two. So after the play, what happened to the deer?
好的。那么，我们再来一条。演出结束后，那只鹿发生了什么？
Oh, we took him home. The play was always put on on Christmas Eve. So we went home, 'cause it would have been, like, 10 o'clock. And of course, Santa Claus was going to come, and we was all excited.
哦，我们把它带回家了。那场戏总是在平安夜演出。所以我们回家了，因为那一定，比如，10点了。当然，圣诞老人要来了，我们都很兴奋。
And so in this version of the story, you guys live happily ever after, right?
所以在这个版本的故事中，你们幸福地生活在一起，对吧？
Yeah, right. Yeah. And then I vividly remember the next morning after. We asked if we could bring him in. And they-- Mother and Dad-- both said yes. So we put a lot of Christmas bows on him, and we let him stay in the house until he wandered into Mother's plants. And then he had to go out.
是的，没错。是的。然后我清楚地记得第二天早上。我们问能不能把它带进来。他们——母亲和爸爸——都说可以。所以我们给它装饰了很多圣诞蝴蝶结，让它留在屋里，直到它溜进母亲的植物里。然后它必须出去。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
Connie Rex talking to me from the ranch where she grew up outside Woodruff, Utah. That interview was recorded back in 2012. I am really sad to say right here that Connie Rex died last year.
康妮·雷克斯在犹他州伍德拉夫外的牧场与我交谈。那次采访是在2012年录制的。我非常难过地在这里说，康妮·雷克斯去年去世了。
Act Three, Replacement Claus. So we end today's show about people who go above and beyond to make Christmas special with the man who does that more than anybody, the gift givingest person there is. He operates on a global scale. I'm talking, of course, about Santa Claus. He is a man who wants for nothing. That is, until things change for him. Jonathan Goldstein explains.
第三幕，替身圣诞老人。所以我们今天节目结束时讲述的是那些超越自我让圣诞节变得特别的人，也就是那个比任何人都做得更多、最会送礼物的人。他在全球范围内运作。我当然是在谈论圣诞老人。他是一个无欲无求的人。也就是说，直到事情为他发生了变化。乔纳森·戈德斯坦解释道。
Each life was a lonely tumble down a cold, dark chimney, falling, falling, then blackness. These were Santa's thoughts as he prepared snicker doodles in the kitchen. In the other room, the elves performed Christmas tunes and do-si-doed. Carefully, he carried the tray of sweets into the living room. His wife, Martha, had been dead five years now, and he was alone-- alone in a house full of elves. Jesus had dignity, apostles. All he had was high blood pressure and a communal toilet the size of a cereal bowl.
每一个生命都是在冰冷、黑暗的烟囱中孤独地滚落，坠落，坠落，然后是黑暗。当圣诞老人准备厨房里的饼干时，这些是他的想法。在另一个房间里，小精灵们表演着圣诞曲子，跳着舞。他小心翼翼地把托盘上的甜点带进客厅。他的妻子玛莎已经去世五年了，他很孤独——在一个满是小精灵的房子里孤独一人。耶稣有尊严，有使徒。他只有高血压和一个燕麦碗那么大的公共厕所。
He sat down on the couch and watched the elves dance to "Feliz Navidad." Jingles broke from the group of dancing elves and approached him. You're killing yourself with the doodles, Jingles said, slamming down his gin rickey. And lately, he'd been on Santa's case to stop overeating, to get out of the house, and to get himself a girlfriend.
他坐在沙发上，看着小精灵们随着《Feliz Navidad》跳舞。金格尔斯打破了跳舞精灵的小组向他走来。“你会用饼干把自己撑死的，”金格尔斯说着，重重地放下他的杜松子酒。最近，他一直催促圣诞老人停止暴饮暴食，走出房子，给自己找个女朋友。
Glenda, the good witch of the North, lived only a few miles away and had just been left by her boyfriend, a walrus hunter who looked somewhat like a walrus himself. Glenda's into the Wilford Brimley type, said Jingles, so you've totally got a chance. Glenda? Said Santa. But she's so sparkly.
北方的好女巫格琳达住得只有几英里远，刚刚被她的男朋友抛弃，那是一个看起来有点像海象的海象猎人。金格尔斯说：“格琳达喜欢威尔福德·布里姆利那种类型，所以你完全有机会。”“格琳达？”圣诞老人说，“但她太闪亮了。”
I miss Martha, Santa said quietly. He knew this was true, though not the entire truth. There was missing, of course, but there was also fear. Look, I miss Martha, too, said Jingles, but it's time to move on. She was the only gal for me, said Santa. Jingles put his tiny hand on Santa's knee. To be frank, Jingles said, I always thought your relationship a little narcissistic. Mrs. Claus was like your twin but with bosoms. Did you plan your outfits together? We just had the same taste, Santa sobbed.
“我想念玛莎，”圣诞老人轻声说。他知道这是真的，尽管不是全部真相。当然有想念，但也有恐惧。“看，我也想念玛莎，”金格尔斯说，“但现在是时候前进了。”“她是唯一适合我的女人，”圣诞老人说。金格尔斯把他的小手放在圣诞老人的膝盖上。“坦白说，”金格尔斯说，“我一直认为你们的关系有点自恋。克劳斯太太就像你的双胞胎，但有胸部。你们在一起计划你们的服装吗？”“我们只是有相同的品味，”圣诞老人抽泣着。
"Jingle Bell Rock" started up on the squeezebox, and Santa took that as his cue to head to bed. He never could stand rock-and-roll Christmas songs. He liked Christmas songs, and he liked rock and roll. He just didn't like them together. Martha had felt the exact same way.
手风琴开始播放《Jingle Bell Rock》，圣诞老人把它作为他上床睡觉的暗示。他从来受不了摇滚圣诞歌曲。他喜欢圣诞歌曲，也喜欢摇滚乐。他只是不喜欢把它们放在一起。玛莎也有完全相同的感觉。
On their first-year anniversary, Martha had presented him with a pen-- the fancy kind that came in a box. Oh, for the love of Saint Nicholas, Santa had said, what good is a pen? I'll just end up losing it. Save your money, and buy yourself something nice, or let me buy for you. That would make me most happy of all.
在他们结婚一周年纪念日，玛莎送给他一支笔——那种放在盒子里的高级货。“看在圣尼古拉斯的份上，”圣诞老人说，“笔有什么用？我最后只会把它丢了。省下你的钱，给自己买点好的，或者让我为你买。那会让我最开心。”
For a man famous for his giving, Santa was terrible at receiving. Martha took the pen back and apologized, and that was the end of the gifts. After she had died, and Santa was cleaning out her stuff, in a jewelry box filled with the old love letters he'd sent during their courtship, he found the pen. He clutched it on the edge of the bed and wept.
对于一个以给予闻名的男人来说，圣诞老人非常不擅长接受。玛莎把笔收回去并道歉，这就是礼物的终结。在她去世后，圣诞老人清理她的东西时，在一个装满他在求爱期间寄出的旧情书的珠宝盒里，他发现了那支笔。他紧紧抓住床边，流下了眼泪。
Jingles took it upon himself to just go ahead and arrange a date for Santa unbidden. Glenda's expecting you at 8:00, said Jingles, sidling up to him in the reindeer stable one morning. And do me a favor. Trim your whiskers and put on your Spanx.
金格尔斯自告奋勇地直接安排了圣诞老人的约会。一天早上，金格尔斯在驯鹿棚里蹭到他身边说：“格琳达在8点等你。帮我个忙。修剪一下你的胡子，穿上你的塑身衣。”
As instructed, Santa appeared at Glenda's doorstep that evening, a paper bag of roasted chestnuts in his hand. Come on in, Mr. Claus, said Glenda, with a sweep of her arm. She was dressed all in white, and the house smelled of fresh gingerbread. Santa observed, with a smile, that there were several magic wands, gold and sparkly, in the umbrella rack.
按照指示，圣诞老人那天晚上出现在格琳达的门口，手里拿着一袋烤栗子。“请进，克劳斯先生，”格琳达挥手示意道。她全身穿着白色，房子里闻起来有新鲜姜饼的味道。圣诞老人微笑着观察到，伞架里有几根神奇的魔杖，金色且闪闪发光。
For most of the evening, they sat by the hearth and made clumsy conversation about the loneliness of living at the North Pole, mostly. Unless I absolutely have to, I don't even bother going outside, said Glenda. And when the cable goes out, it is out, said Santa. After a beat of silence, Glenda looked at him, a smile across her face. Is this a good conversation? she asked. Santa laughed and assured her it was.
大半个晚上，他们坐在壁炉边，笨拙地谈论着居住在北极的孤独感。格琳达说：“除非绝对必要，我甚至懒得出门。”“当电缆断了时，它就断了，”圣诞老人说。一阵沉默后，格琳达看着他，脸上露出了微笑。“这是好的谈话吗？”她问。圣诞老人笑着向她保证是这样。
They played cribbage, drank eggnog, and watched the snow outside the window fall. And in the vestibule before leaving, Glenda placed her hand on Santa's shoulder and kissed him right beneath his eye. As she did, Santa felt as though his chest were a chimney. And inside, a sleeping dove was stirring awake.
他们玩了纸牌游戏，喝了蛋酒，看着窗外的雪落下。在离开前的门厅里，格琳达把手放在圣诞老人的肩膀上，吻了他眼睛下方。当她这样做时，圣诞老人觉得他的胸部就像一个烟囱。里面，一只沉睡的鸽子正在醒来。
They made a date for the following weekend. And just before he left, Glenda gave him a container of cranberry mini muffins she'd baked. Santa told her he could not accept such a gift, at which point, she thrust it into his chest with surprising force. Take it, she said. On the sleigh ride home, Santa realized, with mixed feelings, that he'd hardly thought of Martha the whole night.
他们约定了下一个周末再约。在他离开之前，格琳达给了他一个她烤的蔓越莓小松饼容器。圣诞老人告诉她他不能接受这样的礼物，此时，她以惊人的力量把它推向他的胸部。“拿着它，”她说。在回家的雪橇上，圣诞老人带着复杂的心情意识到，他整晚几乎没想过玛莎。
When he showed up the following Saturday, Glenda was all apologies. Change of plans, she said, stopping him in the vestibule. Sheila's here-- flew in this afternoon from Tampa. Sheila? Asked Santa. A.k.a. The Wicked Witch of the East, she said quickly-- my old college roommate. College? asked Santa. For witches? She's always showing up like this, Glenda went on. Every time there's trouble in Tampa, I get a knock at the door.
当他在接下来的星期六出现时，格琳达全是道歉。“计划有变，”她说，在门厅拦住他，“希拉在这里——今天下午从坦帕飞来的。”“希拉？”圣诞老人问。“也就是东方邪恶女巫，”她迅速说道，“我的大学室友。”“大学？”圣诞老人问，“巫师的？”“她总是这样出现，”格琳达继续说，“每次坦帕有麻烦，我就会听到敲门声。”
In the den, Sheila was lying on the couch in a kittenish tangle, all in black and smoking what smelled like European cigarettes. She studied Santa while playing with her hair. Hey, Chubs, she said. I told you to smoke outside, said Glenda, with exasperation. She went into the kitchen to get some fruitcake as Santa made his way over to the couch. Sheila didn't move. So he squeezed into the corner, her black stocking toes touching his thigh.
在书房里，希拉躺在沙发上，蜷缩成一团猫一样的姿势，全黑的衣服，抽着闻起来像欧洲香烟的东西。她打量着圣诞老人，同时玩弄着她的头发。“嘿，胖子，”她说。“我告诉过你要在外面抽烟，”格琳达恼怒地说。她走进厨房去拿些水果蛋糕，圣诞老人走向沙发。希拉没有动。所以他挤进角落里，她黑色的丝袜脚趾触碰着他的大腿。
So what do you do, fatso? Santa began to stammer. Oh, I-- relax, [BLEEP] hole. I know who you are. You're famous, she said, taking the last cookie from the serving tray. So how do you know Glenda? Oh, we're neighbors, said Santa. And you buy this good witch bull [BLEEP]? she asked in a whisper. A downward turn in the black arts, and all of a sudden, she's moved to the North Pole and rebranded herself a good witch.
“所以你做什么，胖子？”圣诞老人开始结巴。“哦，我——放松，[哔]洞。我知道你是谁。你很有名，”她说，从餐盘里拿走最后一块饼干。“你是怎么认识格琳达的？”“哦，我们是邻居，”圣诞老人说。“你相信这个好女巫的牛[哔]？”她低声问。“黑魔法的衰落，突然之间，她搬到了北极，把自己重塑为一个好女巫。”
Whoever heard of a good witch? Am I right? It's an oxymoron, like baby grand or jolly fat man. Everyone knows fat men are sad. Look at you-- totally depressed. Am I right? I mean, maybe a little, Santa said. My wife recently died. And what's with this Glenda [BLEEP]? interrupted Sheila. Her name's Linda. Often, when Santa didn't know what else to say, he'd break into a jolly-sounding chuckle. He tried it just then, but the chuckle got caught in his throat and came out sounding sweaty and choked. Sheila stared at him.
“谁听说过好女巫？我说得对吗？这像个矛盾修辞，比如大三角钢琴或快乐的胖子。每个人都知道胖子很悲伤。看看你——完全抑郁。我说得对吗？”“也许有一点，”圣诞老人说，“我妻子最近去世了。”“格琳达[哔]又怎么了？”希拉打断道，“她的名字叫琳达。”通常，当圣诞老人不知道该说什么时，他会爆发出一种快乐的笑声。他刚才试了一下，但笑声卡在喉咙里，听起来汗流浃背且窒息。希拉盯着他。
You have this weird crap in your beard, she said. She reached in to pull it out. And as she did, she brought her face in close enough for Santa to smell her. Whereas, Glenda smelled like baby powder and cinnamon, Sheila smelled of something he couldn't quite put his finger on. Cigarettes, of course, but something else, too. It set the chimney in his chest ablaze, ashy black doves trying to flap out their flaming wings.
“你胡子里有奇怪的垃圾，”她说。她伸手去把它拉出来。当她这样做时，她把脸凑得很近，让圣诞老人闻到了她的味道。格琳达闻起来像婴儿爽身粉和肉桂，而希拉闻起来像他无法确定的某种味道。当然是香烟，但还有别的东西。这点燃了他胸中的烟囱，灰黑色的鸽子试图扇动它们燃烧的翅膀。
As Sheila rummaged through his beard, the look on her face was all little-girl concentration. You have nice bone structure, she said. You should try wearing black. It would have a slimming effect. Withdrawing a tiny, shriveled raisin from Santa's beard, Sheila crinkled up her face and flicked it onto the carpet. Ew, gross, she said. Glenda walked back into the room with drinks. And when Santa reached for one, he realized his hand was shaking. He excused himself to use the bathroom, where he thought he might hum a few carols to calm himself down.
当希拉在他的胡子里翻找时，她脸上的表情全是小女孩的专注。“你有漂亮的骨骼结构，”她说，“你应该尝试穿黑色。会有显瘦的效果。”希拉从圣诞老人的胡子里抽出了一颗干瘪的小葡萄干，皱起脸把它弹到地毯上。“哎，恶心，”她说。格琳达端着饮料走回房间。当圣诞老人去拿一杯时，他意识到他的手在颤抖。他借口去上厕所，他想在那里哼几首颂歌让自己冷静下来。
Everything inside the bathroom was glittery and white-- white glittery soaps, shampoos, curtains. But there, hanging from the white shower curtain rod was something black. Strung there for all the world to see were a pair of silky black stockings-- Sheila's black stockings.
厕所里的一切都是闪闪发光的白色——白色的闪光肥皂、洗发水、窗帘。但就在那里，挂在白色浴帘杆上的是黑色的东西。挂在那里让全世界看的是一双丝质的黑色长筒袜——希拉的黑色长筒袜。
For years, Santa had dealt intimately with stockings, stuffing them with coal or presents, and never thought about it twice. But just then, seeing those black stockings of hers, being alone with them, something came over him. And suddenly, he was on his toes, biting the tips like a playful pup-- like a fat, old, playful pup. Returning to the living room, Santa sat back down on the couch and listened, enraptured, as Sheila encouraged him to revise his policy on naughtiness. Santa nodded his head, as though giving her suggestion some thought.
多年来，圣诞老人一直亲密地处理长筒袜，往里面塞煤炭或礼物，从来没多想过。但就在那时，看到她那些黑色的长筒袜，独自和它们在一起，某种感觉笼罩了他。突然，他踮起脚尖，像顽皮的小狗一样咬着袜子尖——像一只肥胖的、老迈的、顽皮的小狗。回到客厅，圣诞老人坐回沙发上，入迷地听着，希拉鼓励他修改关于淘气的政策。圣诞老人点着头，好像在认真考虑她的建议。
In bed that night, Santa replayed each of Sheila's words and gestures. Sheila said whatever she felt like, touching and smelling everything like an animal. She was not afraid to take, avail herself of the world-- drinks, cigarettes, hospitality. Without so much as asking, she'd even plunged her hand into Santa's Shirley Temple, plucking the maraschino cherry right out and using his hat to wipe her hands.
那天晚上躺在床上，圣诞老人重温了希拉的每一句话和每一个手势。希拉想说什么就说什么，像动物一样触摸和闻所有的东西。她不怕拿走，利用这个世界——饮料、香烟、好客。甚至没问一声，她就直接把手伸进圣诞老人的雪利酒里，摘下黑樱桃，用他的帽子擦手。
For Santa, one so in love with giving, he could not help but see before him a kind of black hole-- a sexy and sublime black hole, into which he could deliver forth his greatest gifts. In Sheila, he saw an insatiable hunger for life. With such a woman to give to, to give himself to, it would feel as though every day was Christmas.
对于圣诞老人，一个如此热爱给予的人，他不禁在他面前看到了一种黑洞——一个性感而崇高的黑洞，他可以从中交付他最伟大的礼物。在希拉身上，他看到了一种对生命永不满足的渴望。有这样一个女人可以给予，可以把自己给予，感觉就像每一天都是圣诞节。
When they had made plans for the following weekend, Glenda had asked if Santa could bring along a friend for Sheila. And so he showed up with Jingles. Anything to help a brother out, Jingles had said. Strolling into Glenda's living room, Jingles did that thing where he jumped onto the couch while crossing his legs in midair. He landed right beside Sheila.
当他们为接下来的周末做计划时，格琳达问圣诞老人能否给希拉带个朋友。于是他带着金格尔斯出现了。“为了帮兄弟一把，什么都行，”金格尔斯说。漫步走进格琳达的客厅，金格尔斯做了那个动作，跳上沙发，同时在半空中交叉双腿。他直接落在希拉身边。
You are just too cute for words, exclaimed Sheila. Try anyways, said Jingles, snipping the tip of his cigar. It was the length of his forearm. I'd prefer to keep the house smoke free, said Glenda. More like fun free, said Sheila. Say, what do you call people who live around here, anyway? North Pollacks? We call ourselves Cold Poles, said Jingles. Ever put your tongue on a cold pole, honey? Tends to get stuck there. Sheila slapped him on the head. Dork, she said, laughing.
“你可爱得无法形容，”希拉惊叹道。“无论如何都要试一试，”金格尔斯剪掉他的雪茄尖说。它有一个前臂那么长。“我更喜欢保持房子无烟，”格琳达说。“更像是无趣，”希拉说，“对了，无论如何你叫住在这里的人什么？北极波兰人？”“我们称自己为冷极，”金格尔斯说，“有没有把舌头贴在冷极上，亲爱的？往往会粘在那里。”希拉拍了拍他的头。“呆子，”她笑着说。
Sheila and Jingles had a million things to talk about. All the while, Glenda and Santa just sort of sat there, smiling awkwardly and watching the snow fall. It's an uninhabitable wasteland, Santa heard Sheila say. Tampa sounds awesome, said Jingles. If only I could convince El Jefe over there to move the operation south.
希拉和金格尔斯有无数的话题可聊。一直以来，格琳达和圣诞老人只是坐在那里，尴尬地笑着看着雪落下。“这是一个无法居住的荒原，”圣诞老人听到希拉说。“坦帕听起来棒极了，”金格尔斯说，“只要我能说服那边的老板把行动搬到南方。”
Jingles looked over at Santa and, seeing his bro struggling with his date, decided to kick things into gear. Come on, y'all, said the elf, addressing the group. Gather around for a little spin 'o the bottle. I've got just the one, said Sheila, downing the last of the red wine straight from the bottle. Spin the what? asked Glenda. Sheila rolled her eyes, placed the bottle down on the carpet, and spun.
金格尔斯看向圣诞老人，看到他的兄弟在约会中挣扎，决定启动。“来吧，各位，”精灵对小组说，“聚在一起玩个转瓶子游戏。”“我正好有一个，”希拉说着，直接从瓶子里喝干了最后一点红酒。“转什么？”格琳达问。希拉翻了个白眼，把瓶子放在地毯上，转动起来。
Santa watched the bottle spin with an anxiety that bordered on mania. What if the bottle dictated that he was to kiss Sheila? He would almost certainly die. But he did not have to ponder such a kiss for very long. For soon, the bottle slowed to a halt, pointing directly at Jingles. And when Sheila licked her lips and leaned her face downward, Jingles grabbed her head in his small hands and planted his tiny mouth on hers. Santa felt the chimney fire in his chest snuff out.
圣诞老人带着一种近乎狂热的焦虑看着瓶子转动。如果瓶子规定他必须吻希拉呢？他几乎肯定会死。但他没有太多时间去思考那样的吻。因为很快，瓶子停了下来，直接指向金格尔斯。当希拉舔了舔嘴唇并向下俯身时，金格尔斯用小手抓住她的头，把他的小嘴印在她的嘴上。圣诞老人感到胸中的烟囱火熄灭了。
He and Glenda watched them kiss. Then, after a while, they watched the snow fall. Then they went back to watching them kiss. Eventually, Jingles led Sheila into the vestibule, where he said he wanted to show her the secret to getting the tips of his shoes so curly.
他和格琳达看着他们接吻。然后，过了一会儿，他们看着雪落下。然后他们回去看他们接吻。最终，金格尔斯带着希拉走进门厅，在那里他说他想向她展示让他的鞋尖变得那么卷曲的秘诀。
Left alone and at somewhat of a loss, Glenda got up and fished around in a cabinet drawer beside the couch. Santa thought she might be looking for a game of some sort. But then she said, I have something for you. She held out a glistening package. No way, José, Santa said. I'm the gift giver around here. And it's not even Christmas yet.
独自一人，有点不知所措，格琳达站起来，在沙发旁边的柜子里翻找。圣诞老人以为她可能在找某种游戏。但然后她说，“我有东西给你。”她拿出一个闪闪发光的包裹。“不可能，”圣诞老人说，“我是这里的送礼人。而且现在甚至还没到圣诞节。”
Santa was about to really kick up a fuss. But then, as a downright witchy look fell across Glenda's face, he trailed off. It's nothing that big, she insisted, thrusting the present at his chest. Besides, it was fun trying to find the perfect something for you. And then to actually find it-- there's no greater feeling in the world. But look who I'm telling this to.
圣诞老人正要大发雷霆。但然后，当一种十足巫婆的表情出现在格琳达脸上时，他停住了。“它没那么大，”她坚持道，把礼物推向他的胸部，“另外，尝试为你找到完美的东西很有趣。然后真的找到了它——这是世界上最伟大的感觉。但看我是在告诉谁。”
Hearing her words and seeing the look of excitement on her face, Santa had a puzzling thought. Perhaps he'd somehow misjudged things. Perhaps he'd somehow gotten it wrong. By refusing the gifts people wished to bestow on him, he'd consistently failed to give the experience of giving. He'd hogged that particular pleasure all to himself. And so he took the package.
听到她的话，看着她脸上兴奋的表情，圣诞老人有一个令人困惑的想法。也许他以某种方式误判了事情。也许他以某种方式弄错了。通过拒绝人们希望给予他的礼物，他一直未能给予他人给予的体验。他把那种特殊的快乐独自霸占了。所以他拿过了包裹。
It was flat and square. Tearing the wrapping paper open, he saw it was a record-- Rockin' Christmas Party Songs, Volume 1. He absolutely hated it, not just because the thought of listening to it made him feel like one of those old, white-haired hippies who had to make everything from getting their prostate checked to celebrating Christmas not just a good time, but a rockin' good time.
它是扁平且正方形的。撕开包装纸，他看到那是一张唱片——《摇滚圣诞派对歌曲，第一卷》。他绝对讨厌它，不仅因为想到听它就让他觉得像那些老白发嬉皮士，他们必须让每一件事，从检查前列腺到庆祝圣诞节，不仅仅是好时光，而且是摇滚的好时光。
But it was also one of those gifts that said something about the recipient, something that was hard to swallow, like the gift of a back scratcher that says, you're alone in this world and must fend for yourself, or the gift of a warm house coat that says, your days of party dresses are over. The gift of a perfectly awful Christmas album being handed to you by a woman who liked you said, loud and clear, you must learn to compromise.
但它也是那种对接收者说了一些什么的礼物，这很难咽下，就像一件背部抓痒器的礼物，说，你在这个世界上很孤独，必须照顾自己，或者一件暖和的居家袍，说，你穿派对裙的日子结束了。一个完美的糟糕圣诞专辑被一个喜欢你的女人递给你，清楚地说明，你必须学会妥协。
For after all his years of giving, Santa knew better than anyone that we don't always receive what we want, nor even what we deserve. We receive what life brings us. And when it comes to life, we haven't a choice but to open our arms. I love it, said Santa, with a half smile. Unpeeling the plastic, they placed the album on the record player. Santa held out his arms, and Glenda entered his embrace. And together, they danced about the room as Chuck Berry belted out "Run, Rudolph, Run." And it was almost enough to drown out the sounds in the vestibule.
毕竟经历了这么多年的给予，圣诞老人比任何人都清楚，我们并不总是得到我们想要的，甚至也不是我们应得的。我们得到的是生活带来的东西。说到生活，我们别无选择，只能张开双臂。 “我喜欢它，”圣诞老人半笑着说。剥开塑料，他们把唱片放在唱片机上。圣诞老人张开双臂，格琳达进入了他的怀抱。他们一起在房间里跳舞，查克·贝里唱着《跑，鲁道夫，跑》。这几乎足以掩盖门厅里的声音。
[MUSIC - "RUN, RUDOLPH, RUN" BY CHUCK BERRY]
[音乐 - “跑，鲁道夫，跑” 查克·贝里]
Jonathan Goldstein used to work here at our program and is now the host of the podcast Heavyweight, where he tells amazing true stories about people. I recommend it. You can hear it on Spotify or wherever you get your podcasts.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦曾经在这里为我们的节目工作，现在是播客《Heavyweight》的主持人，他在那里讲述人们惊人的真实故事。我推荐它。你可以在Spotify或任何你获得播客的地方收听。
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed and Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for today's program was Julie Snyder. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes. Additional production help on this rerun from Noor Gill, Stowe Nelson, Beth Lake, and Matt Tierney.
我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德和乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、米基·米克、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。达米安·格雷夫和罗伯·格迪斯提供音乐帮助。这个重播的额外制作帮助来自努尔·吉尔、斯托·尼尔森、贝丝·莱克和马特·蒂尔尼。
Special thanks today to Jon Ronson, Sarah Henderson, Michelle Harris, Richard Stewart, and [? Luke ?] [? Teddy ?] at [INAUDIBLE]. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天特别感谢乔恩·荣森、莎拉·亨德森、米歇尔·哈里斯、理查德·斯图尔特和[？卢克？] [？泰迪？] 在 [听不清]。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心，发送到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, one of the most experienced programmers in public broadcasting. He knows the ingredients you need for any successful radio show. And of course, they are--
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，公共广播中最有经验的程序员之一。他知道任何成功广播节目所需的成分。当然，它们是——
Vegetables, a head of broccoli, and an onion, and one of the bones from the original Rudolph.
蔬菜，西兰花头，洋葱，以及原版鲁道夫的骨头之一。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "RUN, RUDOLPH, RUN" BY CHUCK BERRY]
[音乐 - “跑，鲁道夫，跑” 查克·贝里]